my first two lectures here basically
four different ranges were anything form
forcing moves in the middle game to
forcing exchanges in the end game
basically same idea just well in the end
game it's actually much much more
concrete right if we see a sequence of
exchanges that is winning well it's
pretty much just gonna win the game
right we have started with cuz power of
example is simple one and then we'd seen
Larson and Calvin many other data has
something to do it very for signal well
today I wanted to choose something
completely different we could go on with
most strategy and openings and maybe
tactics and all the usual stuff but I
was thinking that a very interesting
topic will be well hopefully what I'm
going to speak today so before i'm even
going to tell you what is the topic that
I'm thinking or that I want to discuss
let's look at this position this was
played form day like it says North
American open it a tournament in Las
Vegas a very strong tournament that was
worn by my close friend little bit
student team oh gee timmy g with the
black pieces he actually had
unbelievable performance there eight out
of nine like incredible and this was one
important game that he built young
grandmaster alejandro ramirez very quick
game this position came form or the
complicated line white sacrifice the
pawn but we can see that white has some
pressure along the d file or some
potential play 9505 kicking this night
away those squirrels are little bit weak
black played i can tell you black played
here the excellent excellent move h5
it's a brilliant move demo was actually
telling me after
game that he was analyzing this position
for white he wanted to play this with
white and then he found this h5 and he
got to play this position with black
it's a really brilliant move the idea is
that no Queen age 595 no more big
threats over here and the night is going
to find an amazing outpost on g4 when
that queen is going to be out of play
it's really amazingly strong move the
game followed with 95 nitec woke take 94
I will just show this quickly and then
go back to our topic Luke take d7 may be
here we will stop for a minute and let
you think how should black continue here
it's tiny tricky i mean extremely
powerful winning the game pretty much on
the spot but how exactly should black
continue here
if you have just suggestions both ideas
you're welcome to suggest 92 check okay
but then the King let's say 92 will be
played and then black white king will
move to f1 what then and if i take the
Queen on d 8
therefore okay and i will move Mike the
King to e1 we will show it on the boat
in a minute and move the King to e1 so
basically my white king is here your
knight is here Bishop here and I just
took and the night is threatened so you
will take the Queen most likely but then
i will take the walk you will take back
and i will take here and white is a
piss-up right because i want the night
for free basically black will be left
with a bishop bishop in a walk and white
Bishop Knight bishop in a book let's let
us see legislate this line that was
suggested here here we shall pay 6 this
is exactly what we are speaking not
kingi one night a queen check and it
will be black that actually collecting
material but after this is just winning
doesn't matter how I piss up for white
so after all those checks and captures
and many many false signals it's a piece
up okay so it is not 92
Bishop see it ok this was played let's
accelerate it but what after what after
cook takes Queen that's beautiful very
very nice I mean the first instinct of
everyone including myself went emo
showed me the game I can make like night
ignite take take that is probably
slightly better probably white king and
the pieces they are not developed but
amazingly enough that's the big power of
h5 the queen is trapped amazing if g fo
we take it and the Queen goes to g3
night to eat to check ok the game lasted
few more moves ok I guess white was not
in a moody pretty much resigned to you
they could have played Bishop e3 and
here it is possible to take and after
Bishop g2 take the base shop second
you're giving back the exchange with big
advantage worked yet probably work to be
four is the simplest way and then the
other were coming to the file okay but
this was just a cool game but not the
main idea that I have for today my
question is I show this position to some
extremely young smart students that I
have and they suggested or they thought
about the move d6 know k how should
white play after this six because now d
6 has the idea of Bishop c8 immediately
playing against the Queen how should
white continue this this will be
basically the introduction to our main
idea today
as usual I let you have 12 minutes to
think with white then we'll discuss it
and so on
'if I've you mean a five okay and what
after bishops the eighth night XD for
okay but I just have so you want to go
here and if I go Bishop c8 you will g4 I
took this way maybe I have even another
idea but okay now don't even know you
know maybe i can take on these things
maybe i'll just play Bishop f6 just
looks straightforward enough
white is upon down he has to worry about
I think he has to worry about like some
night take if two in many lines move the
Queen away
yes mate but the problem is you have to
move your queen I mean 94 with many
ideas 95 96 it's interesting but I have
night takes f 2 in most of those lines
because the Queen will be under attack
okay it's crazily complicated position I
I don't think it is it will be in white
favor maybe black even has better ways
to play I mean I wasn't even looking at
Bishop take G for that I am pretty
certain is a possibility there after
drift oh so if I bishops the eight you
want to go chief oh okay any other ideas
and what is this position no no I know
how to what do you think about that
position like White's better blacks
better unclear who knows of black okay
so let's look at that position 35 I
think this is the most forcing move I
agree if the night goes back Bishop 86
take on a stick so Bishop c8 is the big
idea right with some ideas of 94 maybe
not that easy to find a decent spot for
the Queen I mean Queen each row is
indeed a possibility actually Nyjah fo
maybe Nyjah Phi something to g5 but i
really want to look at the line that you
suggested so we want to look at take
take take take all right so this is a
very interesting position White has two
bishops in the night nine points of
material basically right around nine
maybe tiny bit more than nine black as
Queen in two points 11 12 points of
material so black is ahead of material
whiter some pieces activity I will let
everyone think for to our usual 23
minutes and then I will ask just just
one question which will be interesting
which color would any of you prefer to
be in this position would you take white
or black after it we will have our
explanations of our discussion but just
first question you know two minutes
white or black so you'll think and then
we'll discuss it a bit
alright you prefer white or black in
this position oh no idea instinct
feeling black black which color you want
to play in this position yes white all
right no color okay okay so three black
one white bubbly white 32 white clip 3
white okay for white all right white
five white my goodness it started with
started with my goodness it was 55 to
know I feel like you know I used to
watch at the beginning after it I got
tired of it like what was the name of
what's the name of this so I think
survival something like this right like
the you know that they've Detroit vote
and they make it so dramatic like
everyone when it flows someone else and
then like everyone you know is voting
someone like so dramatic so if Wow looks
like black is a about to stay and then
suddenly everyone kicked him away
alright i will ask one other question
it's really interesting if i will take
both looks of the boat will anyone
change his vote it's very dramatic if i
take the works from the board would
anyone change his vote
so you will change it from white to blue
from black to white so if i take the
hope you will go from black to white
okay anyone else would like to change
the dramatic vote go from white to black
nobody to black my goodness
the idea of trading down pretty
so so if i'll change the book you will
take black much more yes you'll be much
more oh it anyone else want to think
again about is crucial vote no okay
interesting so i'll tell you what i
think you and then we will see because
hopefully this is what we're going to
discuss today i will take white without
any doubts i think that white is first
of all I think objectively white is
better then I think white is a lot a lot
a lot of play a lot yes this is why i
find i find this topic very interesting
i was analyzing this starts types of
position i will show you the next ones
including games of nakamura games of
only shook games of chronic you know
from us champions we go to world
champions that had same exactly the same
in balance three minor pieces against a
queen and there is amazing amount of
things that we can study but we really
going we'll go to the basic material is
crucial in chess right we spoke about it
in a few few previous lectures but why
material is crucial because the idea
will be that if we have more material we
will have better possibility to control
the board not just logic light we gave
example okay we have 10 soccer players
on the field vs 8 okay you have two
extra players two extra units you have
better possibility to control the field
that should be the logic but despite the
fact that black is up material if we
just calculate it right with our fingers
White has much better possibilities to
control the board it does control the
board indeed is be shops there are some
weak squares here weak squares here why
does a lot a lot a lot a lot of play I
think white is better here actually
usually computers are very very
materialistic so you know I expected I
looked at this position and I liked
white very much immediately and I said
you know even if the computer is going
to say that it doesn't in
I think I'm going to have a fight with
him and I think I looked at that and
know it the interesting part is that it
are not for its let's see if I can use
Houdini here let's see if I can use that
one second for some reason on this
computer they don't have it on another
one they do but if you let him think for
enough time maybe we can do it for a
second the evaluation start is unclear
tiny and it gradually increases I mean I
don't know if he will do it or not but
it should gradually increase into whites
favor and maybe fate is not a strong
enough the deeper DTC's he starts
feeling the dell difficulties for black
ok here is kind of happy with equal but
it is why it's better here why fight him
now why is that we explained it and
without analyzing this position much
much more let's skip to my next question
if we exchange the hooks will it help
white or black and the gentleman over
there was perfectly correct he write a
quite so we are not in getting on that
but if we exchange the works I think
black is going to be much much better or
much better you know let's do it i
actually haven't done it so we're going
to do a little experiment here let's
let's see we take the works of the board
and the wisdom will say that this should
be much in blacks favor
there is a tactic that black is winning
on the spot so let's ignore the tactic
right I mean it's just showing night
deformed like winning on the spot so
let's even be nicer let's give the move
let's see if we can give them move to
white oh you know what let's just put
white king on g2 they want to do it okay
we'll go back we were at this point
because this is a huge important concept
and now let's take our walks of the
board and give why the move so it will
be extra generous for white and let's
put white king on g2 so there is no 94
and then Queenie one check that was some
problem in the previous tactics what's
the position here that is waning two
points of material three points of
material for black how could it be that
when we add the rooks to the board the
position is in whites favor we did
something that is ok right i mean i took
two weeks from this side i took two
looks from the other side this was a
medic a math equation we did everything
legal right everything ok why is this
position winning for black as opposed to
the one before
safer to pick up some of those pawns I
think it's going to be hard for okay I
pretty much agree with everything i will
add this thing of course blacking is
better than before because it's very
difficult for y to attack it I will say
that the big difference is this chest is
a very funny game in the way that we
always say it's material game so you
would say oh the queen is the most
powerful piece on the board which is
true but what happens when a look is
attacking a queen it is not a look that
should be worried it's the queen that
should move away that's very funny right
i mean why plays wookie one it's the
Queen that's going to go away not do so
the more pieces that we add on the board
one unit high-value piece loses its
power just by logic it's it's not easy
to really explain it actually not
biologic by the dynamic of the pieces it
takes a lot of time i tell you i was
looking at this position with strong
players and it's not very easy that
concept I mean that's why I said the
gentleman over there was perfectly right
the mall if I now put four walks on the
board I think frogs for each side think
black is probably just completely losing
because the Queen suddenly is not nine
or ten point it's much much much much
lower it has no room everywhere it will
go there will be something hitting it
everywhere it will go this is why you
know you see in n games two weeks versus
the walk and two minor pieces the first
goal of the player that has the two
weeks versus a look and two minor pieces
let's exchange the works of the boat
let's exchange it let's reduce that
amount of material because then our look
has no match it is much more effective
so this is the first base there and it's
very easy no I showed you the computer
just to show the magnitude of it minus
three disposition and I gave white also
the
move minus 3 basically black is winning
the other position white is better so
this is just a line from this game and I
remember I was analyzing it and it was
very you know several young kids you
know ten years old out two thousand some
of them tying a lifetime of them tiny
ball really really very strong kids
though top in the country for their age
now let's see how this is really
happening in real life and not just
really happening but how it is happening
even it more at a higher level of
thinking not just fair trade sometimes
the one that has the pieces in the
dynamic will be willing to give material
to avoid fair trade just to keep their
initiative this is why chess is not very
easy for computers if it was just simply
adding well 40 years ago computers would
kill human right 30 years ago death
dynamic between the pieces is really
really not easy this is a game played in
US Championship between Alexander only
shook I'm not mistaken he was US
Champion in 2006 playing against this in
great American grand master Eugene
pearlstein they played the Grunfeld d5
queen bee three this is the Russian
variation one of only shook very
favorite lines also Karpov each one of
his very favorite lines played quite
enough games in this although against
God's power most of the games went with
classical capture and e fo and so on ok
so without too much analysis of the
opening I want to go to our crucial
position Bishop e2 I will just move tiny
slower for the gentleman playing on the
board b5 Queen 396 okay there are many
many theoretical lines i think c5 is one
line [ __ ] if I ok whenever white just a
general one minute concept of this
opening whenever white is ready to play
this move is
basically ready to sacrifice the screen
for three pieces because after Bishop e6
if white is going to move the screen he
gave this square for free why play d5
because black could not conquer the D
Phi square you could not block head over
there so after Bishop e6 if I just move
black plays 95 and it should be quite
happy you kissed it reasonable so take
take take take all right we have exactly
the same material balances before
exactly queen and two pawns versus two
big shots and a night exactly and that
will be also our material balance in the
next games so we already know right now
if someone asks you what happened if i
take the oaks from this position you
look at them and tell them easily or
black is waning the pieces can do
nothing they cannot tickle the black ink
they can do nothing no possibilities to
attack those balls will be constantly
week black might create a passport you
will push the pulse here there is
nothing to bother the queen but there
are two books on the boat okay castle
attacking the rook
what should black play here
look to the eighth i will assume hook a
2d eight right obviously okay [ __ ] the H
is a decent move any other ideas
take the pond and it will intentionally
lose the exchange for the bishop all
right I don't know if it is right idea
bad idea about at least decent enough
for Grandmaster with the black pieces
all right so we'll take it as a decent
one excellent what did why play here
excellent idea
is there anyone that with a hand on his
heart in a real game that will not take
here you will take you will not take so
what will you play Bishop d5 okay i will
move my queen then you'll take okay so
you will take it to move after right
okay Oh Quincy to maybe even Quincy to
it's a bit better I don't know okay will
you take their look all right that would
be a first engine but you know it's
interesting because our gentleman there
maybe you'll tell me your name so i
might add Radha okay was saying before
something let make it made a lot of
things lots of all from chess point of
view it was brilliant it was excellent
intentionally give the rook but you know
I always say the chest is reasonably
okay to play to play good chess moves is
very difficult but to understand chess
is very easy to players white black
whatever is good for white it's bad for
black whatever is good for black is bad
for white it's very easy right only two
players you know not complicated so if
you want intentionally for me to take
here with white then I won't do that
right I won't do that you know if I have
something better I will not because you
will brilliantly right that's perfect
you know we said and this will be our
topic for the next two positions it is
about controlling squares when you give
this Bishop that is worth three points
yes you will tell me oh but now I'm only
down right now its screening three pawns
let's say white is down three points you
will be only down one point but you have
lost every possible control that you had
over there light squares not easy to
attack right now for white this outpost
all those squirrels that white had
possibilities to control with this
Bishop our God it's very very difficult
concept the only cause the only way that
I can explain it is that really it's
about controlling squirrels about what
helps me control the most space and I
don't care which piece is going to be
you know I'm thinking as a joke Mike ed
is very smart about just but it doesn't
like to play any never played even one
tournament in his life but I remember he
wants to invented a piece if flamingo
it's a combination of the Queen in the
night that would make my chest life so
easy if I had one piece that can move
like a queen n like a night together
would control bazillion squares right a
bit more difficult in chess but only
shook you know yours champion a member
of the Olympic team for about ten years
basically is telling us more than ten
years is telling us dude this Bishop in
this position is doing more than this
work is more important than this hook
especially when it's combined with two
other minor pieces against the Queen so
we didn't take play 95 which you
couldn't play because if you had given
the bishop he wouldn't have access to
this square e6 was played without
analyzing much that's not our job maybe
hoop dat is a better move I'm pretty
certain if we put it on the computer the
computer is going to like black no doubt
but you know black is just a decent
grandmother I say just you know it's of
course a strong player white is a very
strong player bouquet Trey was played
now already starting to be some
difficulties if Queen goes to sea for
maybe hook c3 and possibilities for at
some point B 3 and suddenly this Bishop
will be in the game so black decide
to give away a screen just to reduce the
pressure right or wrong okay I think I'm
not certain it is the right decision but
bet what was played and here I'll just
give two three more minutes to this
position it is beautiful because the way
the tuna should play the rest is we'll
just see it for two more minutes we
would take immediately but that will
play into blacks idea what those hooks
need what what work needs to be powerful
open fast so you play Bishop takes d5
Luke a d8 will be played and lake is
immediately playing this deep one is
meaningless as long as white can now go
after this one and then the bishops are
going to control everything so the c7
point is under bigoted a crook f7 is
impossible if you create either take
down on d 50 maybe if this move will be
played maybe when he shook would just
put this book here so c6 was played look
how what happened to black pawns 12 back
desperate to exchange looks you know
look if we will have this position
without their looks oh that's easy for
black much I mean maybe it still words
are actually I'm I don't think so but
black is desperate to exchange it we
just mentioned when you have big piece
big value versus to you want to get rid
of all the rest almost always the
problem for him is that it cost him a
bit it cost him another point c 7 d 5 ft
six okay so we did each he achieve this
goal but he paid a big price is just now
down to be soft or a walk the pawns are
equal y took three pawns in the last
item five more seven moves and white
went on and won the game the key
bringing the king and so on by the way
this is a platy also move because he
wants to keep the pawns on this side you
believe the tea has more power look at
those bishops and okay the rest is took
this one the pawn is meaningless look at
the bishops I mean you should take a
picture and see how the bishop control
really everything and went on to win the
game